welcome to this video playing agent Fox
Mulder Japan maybe never know those
exotic flex listen chest Japan is pretty
exotic check sometimes not really used
by people from that country just for fun
ok the regos in popular opening line
nowadays and I always play this because
I don't know anything sharper but I
think it's quite okay for white also
been played by cards in in games
successfully what is basically saying
okay I know your position is quite okay
but don't you have that knight on c6
which is kind of wrong yeah this is what
white claims and with some justification
so yeah now he has to attend to that d
50 site and now you will probably play
Bishop t6 and I'm going back my DS night
a 42 c 5 and i will go for that
yeah basically I'm trying to play some
type of minority attack on the queenside
and black walls right you get something
going on against my king possible so
nice to see Five he's got a bishop to
see eight ok because Bishop c8 and I
play queen bee three what does this move
then I attack bee7bea 696 is a pawn I
don't know so you just take you 1 c 5
maybe
Bishop Bishop takes d5 is really a move
that you don't want to play of Bishop on
d success is really am a key piece in
any King side counter play but maybe
maybe you have to I don't know the i
will take b7 yeah but this is this is a
case where I'm probably the cure is
worse than the disease at least I I know
I don't really believe that that you can
weaken yourself like that okay question
is how to play it down 93 and something
to e5 is probably right not sure ever
should take but let's open up the a file
I wonder if a like Bishop g4 is
something for him that doesn't help him
him that much c6 is still fairly um
fairly solid but it's still a week pawn
I mean it is weak and just have to get
added if it goes be sure before i think
i will play Queen d1 and tending not f2e
5 i'm pinning and I want the night only
five I really wondered there okay so
Luke c6 is answered by um bishop age to
that I understand I go back here Bishop
d7 95 isn't that ok you can drop back to
see idea ok
cute move didn't think of that one can't
go to a head now until I cannot check
because of Bishop age too funny
still the bad structure is not going
away it just is a fact that porn is on
c6 and it won't move ever okay check he
has to take with the bishop not oops
what's that so um context gives me the
default square but still it doesn't make
much sense I think to give him a five
for the night let's say yes that's the
that's the kind of perfect scenario here
against that c6 porn just just excellent
okay he tries to throw a spanner in the
works hmm interesting I can go back
there all right I didn't see the move
but it doesn't really change things that
much check again the structure is there
and this will stay bad and most end
games are bad rook endgames night
against bishop in particular would be
terrible if I'm 9595 he might just
secondly exchange hmm yeah
okay i can i can prepare that
queen is Quincy fiber move probably not
I'd like to go 95 without him even
giving the possibility to play play the
sacrifice I mean it's not dangerous but
anyway and it's a good a file yeah this
is a moment where Quincy five is
actually interesting and then the night
to deform let's do that so I'm pretty
pretty good good moment transforming
advantages
so what to do yeah something like night
at five might might work time morning
and I just I'm with my king in the game
whoa really hmm I mean at some point I
will take it yeah just it just gives me
that pawn as well I will take it yeah
well I can also play now I check on c1
yeah check on c1 so what is what is the
best here actually this is winning the
bishop right check
check king of 8 19 CR 96 I could have
taken it but ok it's the same thing
essentially check just a piece black for
effects on time yeah so let's have a
look there the real issue was a shock
wave III a belief you should just take
that even though it's not the most
attractive-looking news so here queen
bee three I think you just should just
take it the engine is giving a five
that's interesting the ideas this year
funny well that's interesting but yeah
this is not I mean very attractive but
it's okay you can put the night over
here to the zero sorry to d6 and
different defend this position nothing
problematic and TM this is really an
awful structure check yeah now I'm
getting that dark squared Bishop makes
the dark squared weaknesses even more
pronounced check Tim that it just it's
just too bad c6 is bad the bishop is is
just wrong in relation to the pawn
structure there all the time in the
world
now I get to deform the rookie for
didn't help he has to has to put put put
up some some kind of passive defense
hear something like that yeah yeah and
I'm going to invade you with the king
that that's going to to lose but it's
probably has to do it I don't see
anything else rupee for was even quicker
in and going downhill essentially i
think really be five I don't like that
p5 seems to be to weakening okay well
thanks for watching